hi guys welcome to so my
are taken and I will be driving this
presentation on the watch shop on
scrappy so before before we move on let
me like try to understand the crowd how
many of you are from or students or from
academics may not be student okay so if
your student okay
so rest of the people or like working
for some company and programmers okay
good so and like how many of you already
have done some sort of scraping so have
you used scrappy before or aware of
scrappy you are okay so it might be a
little basic for you guys like whoever
have already done our you scrappy but
definitely like those who haven't like
used creepy it would be a interesting
workshop I believe so the the primary
motive of this workshop is when you go
out if you can like do some of your own
scraping projects like to solve some of
your problems for example if you had to
know like all the speaker list of this
conference you could do that really
easily like you can get the jump off all
the speakers and then sort it and do
whatever you want these kind of small
projects if you are able to do so that
achieves my goal is what I believe okay
so from next like the questions wise you
can you can ask if you are not following
anything of the workshop but if you want
to like keep some discussion kind of
topics like whether scraping is really
legal ethical those kind of questions
let's keep it to the end okay
no end of the end of the presentation
maybe I will be around to discuss around
that so what happened to this
okay Oh
okay so what you're going to do is first
I'll give you some explanation on
scraping generic and then about
introduction to scrapy and then we will
do a small exercise hands-on which
should be really interesting so I will
help you with like how to install you
don't have to worry about it okay so
let's let me give you a brief
introduction myself of Kartik an anti
lead professional services I had this
department so I'm not an engineer now
any engineer was supposed to come here
but unfortunately he couldn't come and I
am replacing him so you guys may have to
help me with some syntax or some problem
happens okay so and I have a vision to
synergize data generation and analytics
and we are working towards that so
professional services is a around 50
engineers team in scraping hub so I lead
the department also a open source
promoter like each of our engineers are
allowed to like what 10 to 15 percent of
their time to contribute on open source
sorry ok so professional services is
like doing scraping projects for
customers so sorry oh yeah any industry
so yeah we are a very small company
don't have like verticals as such
defined so we work on like all segments
like any scraping project that comes to
us will be under my department does that
answer your question there are no
verticals are such defined everything is
ecommerce ecommerce is the main thing
and sometimes news ok
so let's move on likewise web scraping
why can't we use api's so that's a
primary question people ask so api's
will have liked a lot of limitations the
sometimes they don't update what is
there on the website and ApS will have
lot of restrictions and also like there
will be some competitive information
that was that would be needed like
imagine if Best Buy goes and ask a
Amazonia we want your price of these
products at what price you are selling
at whatever the maison du will slap on
the face right so we we can't relay on
api's for certain information but
competitive information is definitely
needed because consumers who are we we
will get advantage out of that
so if competitors have competitive
information they can select a very
competitive price and we consumers will
get benefitted out of it right so ApS
may not be the solution always but of
course if you have some api's it's
recommended to use rather than doing web
scraping if you get all the information
you use api's otherwise we have to stick
to web scraping so another new thing
that is coming up with Semantic Web so
which is which is like how do you
understand the data in the NA website so
but so like over all around like five
percent of overall websites user stays
so it's not it matured enough or it may
not get matured enough also I am Not
sure but as of now Semantic Web cannot
be used because only five percent of the
website users start ok so what is web
scraping so this is a formal definition
like get the structured data of out of
unstructured websites like websites
displays data in its own way you want to
get it in a structured format like JSON
CVS or whatever it is for further
analysis so this web scraping is about
getting data from an unstructured source
which is which is mostly web web
ages into a structured data Oh case yeah
so scrape from websites I mean you need
to know like what so what I'm going to
talk about mostly website not other
sources it's it's for websites not
mostly but scraping is a bigger
terminology you can like do scraping on
databases and different sources but this
top this talk is only for web scraping
okay so what for so we need a reason for
scraping right so first and foremost is
like monitoring price as I already spoke
about like you need to have competitive
information and monitoring prices of
competitors is one of the things so we
have a project where like we scrape
around like thousands of retailers to
get the competitive information so this
is one of the things and lead generation
you need to have like customer contacts
all those things can be done and
aggregate information we did a recent
project where we collected all the
articles related to Canada elections and
then give it at one place so if the if
there was a duration of one month and
then you have to like collect all the
articles in that time related to Canada
elections so if you had to happen to do
this manually it it wasn't possible at
all like with web scraping we scrape it
around like 30 30 to 50 web news sources
scraper filtered all the articles
related to elections and then give it in
one place and your imagination is limit
so can you can you guess like can you
tell like any anyone can can you tell
some of the use cases of scraping which
you may have phased or you how in your
imagination anybody hmm search engine
yeah search engines uses lot of spiders
like they scrape and then so they go to
each and every websites and look for
keywords yeah great example sorry yeah
definitely yeah generating sales leads
so you can get the contacts and filter
based on based on the customer profile
and use the data so we have done a
project where we collect some of the
information and put it into the
Salesforce directly so very good example
okay so what's warm
so are you like convinced like web
scraping is a thing that you need to do
and learn okay I need some of the
feedback guys otherwise I will get bored
okay so if you want to like do web
scraping one of the things you need is
HTTP you have to literally speak HTTP
right so we have to understand HTTP very
very well and funny when you go out you
should be like talking hey get HTTP 1/1
Berger and the server says 200 okay
right so that is there's a kind of like
involvement you should have like you
should understand really well okay and
okay so these are the standard standard
headers of HTTP protocol you have like
get a get to get the data opposed to
pour like generate the data on the
server and put is update the data head
is to request only headers which is a
standard protocol methods I think we
have like some more methods which is not
captured here but the slide here is to
like let you know like HTTP is very
important to know why
when you have like two web scraping yeah
so it's a method so you have a resource
and a method associated with this and
the server behaves differently based on
the method you give so the normally when
you make a web request on on a browser
it will be get and when you when you
click on a forum post a forum it will it
would be post typically may not be
designed such a way you can design
anyway put put is a it is a principle of
rest resource representation state
transfer so put is used when you have to
update an existing record so you already
have a record on the server and you need
to update it post yes
you can use post also and handle on the
server side to just update Oh check and
this record already exists do an update
you can do that but rest says it's
better to use put there because it's an
update and HTTP equivalent for update is
put yeah yeah you have to do a post and
then yeah yeah okay and query query
string except languages are there like
the websites except certain languages
and then user agent so you you can
change the user agent if you have if you
have observed in the in your mobile
phone you can actually request desktop
site is an option there so what happens
typically is your mobile spoofs itself
as it's a it's a desktop so that way you
will get the complete webpage which you
will see on a on on a on a desktop right
so you can play around with this you can
spoof the requires acting as like I'm a
mobile for mobile device I'm a desktop
whatever it is you can change the user
agents so these things are possible okay
so next let's perform a request what do
you need to do a request program
matically you read lib URL lip - this is
a standard Python library where you can
like to so many HTTP requests so but
it's really messy complicated so we have
something called Python requests which
which is made easy which which which we
I think it's it's on you are a lip built
over you are a lip too but it's much
more easier to use ok so let's do some
coding so this is a very basic request
import requests and get some URL so
let's see you let's see what happens
can I reduce the font of page
texts okay where did I get so I get all
the HTTP of this request okay so
basically what we did we
programmatically did a request to the
website and then we got some HTML so
what do we do with this HTML so we got
HTML but there's no use of it but we
have to do something to get interesting
information out of it right so any
guesses what what we have to do next if
we have HTML like to get the information
that is important to you like what do
you have to do exactly so what are the
ways two parts how do you parse XPath
exactly so if if anyone is thinking like
you can use regex
forget it so it's it's mess - like -
parsing using regex
for HTML basically because it's it's not
a regular language right so there is no
syntax if you just ignore the tag it
works and it's really hard to find a
particular information using regex
this is a standard Stack Overflow
comment on that
so it's no use now because you know
already X part should be used so L XML
as someone pointed already is the
pythonic binding for a lip xml - and lib
XSLT so it's very fast and it gives the
power of expert as well as the speed of
C language scrapey is uses x-l xml so
that and we have another HTML parsers as
well beautiful soup it's it's it's a
wrapper around HTML parser l xml and
HTML 5 lib 2.7
okay okay so we know we got to know like
what needs to be done after we get the
HTML so which is parsing so let's do
some parsing so this is how you do a
basic parsing so you have just taken the
schedule by con 2015
sorry PI data 2015 schedule and then I
have parse it for speakers okay so it
uses the HTML here sorry X part here and
then you do you get the information
needed like text and H ref let's run it
oh oh okay Oh God to get my credentials
No yeah yeah I'll share that but I don't
think these snippets are there but the
main exercise we are going to do that
you have if you guys like feeling bored
or and if you want to like get into the
exercise directly like please let me
know so completely okay with that
what's happening
okay anyway forget it let's move on I
think it should have like given I had
tested a while ago I don't know what
happened suddenly
so maybe Murphy's Law so this this
should have like given all the speaker
list of this conference it goes to the
schedule page and then scrapes all the
speakers name that's what it's trying to
do it's it's getting the export here the
speakers X pot and then get the text and
the H ref associated with that and
printing those that's what it is doing
from string so this this this will yeah
I think it way it creates a tree I'm I'm
really not sure about that sorry
apologize for that but yeah I believe it
should create a tree out of that and
then get the speaker list okay so yeah
so and then like this is a statement to
like through the power of X pot so if
you like whoever wants to like try
reinvent the expert will like mostly
fails and because export is so powerful
and if you want to like do parsing like
that is the one thing you should really
really learn there's no other way you
can do parsing as of now so okay so now
we got to know like we can do a request
do the parsing and get the data
important data that we need why do we
need scraping right so okay and it gets
us like if you if you want to like run
this core you can you can run one
request works and if your boss ask ask
you to like run 1 million requests what
would happen hmm yeah you'll get banned
that's one problem before that
that is another problem yeah it it will
take ages because this is a blocking
call this particular call is a blocking
call and it won't come back till till
the request is sir it it just blocks
there so what typically happens is like
this so this the biker there is can go
faster but he's blocked by very slow
moving request there so you can't really
like old take those so what we need is a
framework which is based on event-driven
or asynchronous you make a request go
back and then once the request is
received you should have a call back
such that you can do something with
those responses right so it's an
event-driven Mecca event bricken driven
framework is needed which is why you
need a framework similar frameworks such
as scrapey scrapey is based on twisted
which is a event driven framework ok it
gets clear okay so scrape is open-source
collaborative framework extracting data
you need websites enforceable it
extensible way so yeah so basically you
can write so many extensions to it right
so you can write extension and use it in
different spiders you write one
extension and use multiple spiders and
and also like you can contribute to the
extension repository like you can write
so many extract extensions and then keep
it and use it in different spiders so
open sourced and like highly used and so
mean I think there was some some number
per day downloads you J forgot like 2000
downloads per day or something ok so
let's move on to the most interesting
part of the workshop which is exercise
so
in this exercise we are going to do find
out all the restaurants around this
place okay and then do some analytics
over that okay so based on like what
rating rating the restaurants has and
then we will create some analytics
that's a moti of this exercise so first
of all you would need scrapey to do this
and this is how you install scrapie do
you all have Conda installed so if you
have Conda installed this is the command
to use if you don't have Conda you can
install it quickly so you just go to
Conda website and install the mini Conda
there
yeah Conda is basically yeah you can but
it might have some something may not
work some dependencies so Conda always
works it's already compiled as well
you can like use pip as well let make
sure the dependencies are installed no
no nothing is new scrape is new Skippy
is already installed
don't you need not do all these things
github link for yes so I can show but
what I've
but we are going to create this code so
hands-on so why is this network so slow
again hard to like login back
are you guys know for facing any problem
with network
Oh
let me just data rate
okay
so let me know like if you're all set
with once the scrape is installed
anybody's still installing
beep installed requests okay so yeah
yeah yeah yeah to execute request you
need to install requests right but
scrappy you know you don't need that so
you need L XML but tight gets
automatically installed okay so cash
anymore
okay so whoever installed you can you
can execute this command shell and give
a gtp come so that should work is it
working hmm yeah I can give you a new
URL I just give example.com you should
also add the scheme HTTP colon slash
slash example.com is it working
okay let me do it again scrappy she'll
example.com okay this is just a test
your installation is fine and working
well yes
so here you can do like so many this is
this is an important aspect of scrapey
like you will get a Python prompt here
and do so many things here like for
example response dot URL you will get
and then you can do response expert so
this is we are directly entered into the
world of scrapey where you can do
response dot expert to get the element
h1 / text thank you
okay so you get example don't mind so if
you go back and check in example.com
you'll have this as the h1 h1 this
example don't mind so that's how you can
easily use expert response dot expert
and give the expert you'll get there you
will directly go to the element okay so
this is so I all did anybody find issues
doing this okay okay let's move on to
the next aspect where you're going to
create a scrappy project okay so to
create ache to create a scrappy project
so this is that you can come out of the
shell ap Start project can q pi data I
am giving PI D top five because I
already have project still is PI data
for know if you have three five install
did you install using Condor gets creepy
how did you install this creepy okay so
you can quickly install Condor that will
also install a Python package yeah I'm I
need to give that command scrapey short
project scrape is short project give you
a project name
okay scrappy stored project give a
project name that should create you a
new project if you get into the project
you should have some directory structure
something like this so it will have PI
data inside that some items pipeline
settings spiders and scrapie door
configuration okay I'll just import this
project into PyCharm so that I can edit
it easily
okay so this is how the folder structure
gets created and first thing I want you
all to do go to settings and uncomment
this this line HTTP cache enabled true
okay this basically doesn't make so many
requests to the website we are going to
hit two to be nice to the website go to
settings dot pi and uncomment HTTP cache
enabled
okay yes sittings dot bye and then go to
around hich is such for HTTP cache
said settings file is blank
no no settings file should get created
open the file bi settings to settings
dot PI you think you were opening the
wrong file yeah this one settings dot
bye okay so why we are doing this is so
there is a cache like on disk cache once
we enable this all the requests made
will be like stored responses will be
stored on the disk so second time when
you make the same request it don't
actually go to the website it will serve
from the disk so just to be nice to the
website like all of you will be hitting
the same website you shouldn't like make
more so many requests so that's the
reason you need not do this always for
your projects yeah I think there should
be something of that sort are also
so but this this thing is only for this
this exercise because all of us will be
eating the same website we don't want to
like overload the website so you need
not do this always if you are learning
the spider for once or twice it's fine
you need not to this case enabled and
and for the further if the data size is
huge you may end up like putting lot of
on your disk which may not be needed
right so we is fokin ly about one second
one yeah okay okay so let's get back to
some of the theory again before we move
on to the coding so what is a spider
right so spider this is a very basic
spider right so if you if you just
inherit scrapey dot spider the class
will become a spider right so this this
is the basic spider that is can be
written like what is happening is you
give a name to it and they define what
allowed what are the domains allowed and
then give you a start URL what what it
does is it will go to the start URL and
start making requests and then once the
responses come response arise it will it
will execute the parts function okay so
basically you make a request and once
the response is there it will go and
execute execute the parts function and
you have the response there and you can
do whatever you want
so this basic spider is just logging
logging whatever you get right logging
logging a message that's all with with
the response URL this this is the basic
spider in it itself okay so are you guys
clear like how to auto create a basic
spider is you inherit scrape it out
spider and make a class
the class that inherits creepy door
spider becomes a spider and you define a
parse to do how you have to parse the
response so clear as back from the back
there are you guys following
the second part is once the response
arrives so well what how does it get
executed is once you run the scrappy
spider I'm going to show how to run this
spider in a while once once you run the
spider what happens is it will go to
this go to the start URL and start
making requests once the response
arrives
this parts gets executed okay so first
part is making the request second part
is parsing the response so here you
write code to parse the response so this
is this is doing very basic thing it is
just logging logging your message that's
all but you can do lot more things in
parsing like for example do the XPath
and get the data we are going to do that
anyway okay so to make clear like how to
execute these things let me just execute
this spider go to the name of the spider
example.com logging spider logging
spider given this different name how do
you execute a spider so once you create
this small purple spider you go scrapey
crawl and give the spider name
so this is this is from the normal shell
normal shell because creepy is the
command that's already installed and
scrappy takes arguments like crawl and
then the spider names yeah yes creepy
has should have been imported here here
okay so if you run the spider okay see
here info a response response from
example.com just arrived so we are just
logging the information in this spider
so basically basically what happened it
went to this start URL made a request
and then came here and then printed log
adjust this message not fitting into my
screen I think
here
Oh
it's correct only huh
okay sorry about that
okay so so parse it's it's when we
execute it we just log in a message but
we need to do like little more complex
things this is very simple so let's see
how we can do that so
so next spider this is a little more
complicated little more not complicated
little interesting so in this Python
what we are going to do is making a
request to the same example comm website
and in the parsing we are doing little
more things what we are doing going to
do is get all the h3 text and then yield
it okay this is this is very important
thing you should know once you do this
in parse once you eat something what
happens is it will be collected as an
item okay item and that those items can
be like rotated to your output file
okay so I'll show you how how this will
help eel ding your message you will get
the data in in a separate file ok once
once we execute you will understand but
what we are trying to do in this part is
we are going after h3 text and then
title title is h3 we are we are yielding
that what what do you mean by Eldin is
that becomes an item in the output file
I'll show you once we execute this here
and we are also going after all the
Hetch rafts that means in a page if you
have any URLs right URLs we are going
after those URLs what this is doing is
scrapy dot request is actually creating
a new request out from from the response
you got and in that response you have a
URL in it and then you are creating a
request to that URL again it will come
to a second request is made and the
second request also comes to the same
function pass and then finds if there
are any h3 here so are you getting your
records you call here so first of all it
goes here comes two parts and then else
the h3 in that page and then goes after
all the URLs in that page makes a
request to that yes
yes absolutely this this this will also
a make a synchronous call sorry so those
those controls are there like you can
set the concurrency how many concurrent
requests you should make normally we
will do like eight twenty or based upon
the website how how address you you want
to scrape you can control that there are
settings for that ends creepy is it
clear guys very ok so when you when you
when you do scrapey crawl example.com
okay you have to execute this from the
project folder sorry I might have missed
that
scrapy command what's only likes creepy
crawl what's only from a project folder
yeah I so we are in the samples project
so I had created a samples project
beforehand okay and then we'll see what
are all the spiders we have inside
samples there will be another samples
folder created inside this there should
be a folder called spider spiders ok and
here you are seeing all the spiders so
this particular program is item creator
ok
let me let me show in in PyCharm it is a
little better so this is this is this
this folder gets created when you do
start project and inside samples inside
spiders here is the spider core item
creator okay so I am in this folder I
think it should be it doesn't matter I
think anywhere in the folder project
folder it should work he crawl items
creator test should execute this come on
so I will just route this to output file
okay okay so what I did is I just
executed this particular program okay so
which which you saw on the slide I have
changed the name forget don't worry
about that
hey it's okay so and then this one this
spider has been executed using the
command scrappy scrappy crawl item
creator and - Oh output dot CSV so that
means I want to collect all the output
data in output dot CSV - y few queue so
what happens is if you see output dot
CSV you will get whatever you have
yielded actually so this is title is the
heading and example domain is what you
have got right so that is the importance
of yielding something so that's how if
you yield in in parse function you will
get that items in the output file right
so whatever whatever the important
information that you need to collect
that should be yielded like that okay
okay so yield scrapie dot request is
actually making more requests but this
example domain does not have any other
URLs there is only there is no other
URLs there is there is one URL here but
it's going to a different website so and
it's getting filtered actually so if you
see in the log will get to know that it
has been like filtered off-site so that
means this this website has been like
filtered we actually did a request here
but we filtered that because a load
domains only example.com is allowed okay
okay so this this is basically to do
more requests okay so guys following any
questions back side that side
you guys okay okay let's move on okay
let's move on to the distinct original
problems like you have like learnt to
create basic spiders let's try to do
some interesting stuff as I told like we
will try to figure out all the
restaurants close to this place okay so
I will be like doing this project I
would like to like you also like to
write the code we should be able to do
in it in 15 minutes or so
so that you will also have the project
in hand after we finish this exercise
okay
okay get to the new project that you
have created
and then go go to this for a spiders
folder and then create a new Python file
called TripAdvisor okay so we are going
to scrape TripAdvisor for all the
restaurant details around this area
first of all imports creepy and then
create a your first spider what I have
to do now how do you like create your
own spider
yes creepy dot spider
so that becomes your spider next give a
name wiser give a lot domains
what tripadvisor.com come and then start
URL URLs it should be a list okay now we
have to find out from where to start
right so which Allah allowed to miss
right thank you okay so now you have to
find from where to start if you start
scraping tripadvisor.com it will take
ages to complete right so we have we
should have a filter list so let's go to
the website and find out where is that
filter list
okay so near to so this is already
existing eating so New York City and
then go for restaurants got lot lot of
restaurants but if we may have to like
find an area which is close by to us
Modelling link okay there is okay okay
yeah I think yeah that's that's fine I
think so here there are so many offices
and we in it this Tribeca there is one
area here so here also there is Tribeca
which I already knew so we can go and
filter based on Tribeca this is one of
the areas ok filtered it and then we got
less number of restaurants around this
area ok so now now this this is the URL
which is which is generic if you go to
this there won't be filtered list okay
what is that what happens is it will
show start showing all the strengths
list sorry
okay so this is the exact URL actually I
think this is this might be like taking
in cash or something on the search
results but this is the URL where you
will get filtered list even if you do it
on on a different browser so this has
around like 10 to 10 pages into around
like 30 which is or close to 300
restaurants around Tribeca area okay so
what we need to do is we have to start
with this URL our scraping should start
from this URL so I give this URL clear
okay now the scraping starts with this
URL so the response will have all these
all these restaurants and everything so
we need to we need to get information
really of of each restaurant okay
so let's do step by step here okay
okay so what we need to do is we have to
get to this this page to get the name
and the rating and the location of the
of each restaurant so so to get the URL
of that that we need to find out what is
the export of this link okay
this is this is a class title h3 class
title right so what we need to do is h3
a class equal to title chill off H ref
okay let's let's verify if this export
works
a slash chef okay here is /hf okay so
this export should work let's verify
once again okay we got thirty thirty URL
so what this expert will give links to
all these these hyperlinks okay all
these individual restaurants let's do a
quick check thank you
okay so I'm just trying to like figure
out what who do we get the right links
here okay we can we can run this
how could something happened it is
giving expert only the object so we may
have to do something here extract
okay cool we got URLs but this is not
absolute URLs
this is relate you let's do that let's
get absolute URL is it good response dot
you or I will join so these are the
scrapey of functions URL this should
give us the absolute URL
oh that's right okay so let's verify so
a couple of URLs if we are getting the
right URLs okay no boo here
no boo is here and another one prime and
yeah so it's here okay so we get got all
the URLs so you're we retrieve the URLs
for each of the pages that we need yeah
that's what we are going to do now so
this was a test okay we got all the URLs
that we need so next what we need to do
is so we should we shouldn't be yielding
here so rather we have to make a request
for each of those URLs right so what we
will do here is make a request it's
there is there any problem what's
happening
yeah oh sorry not this one oh yeah yeah
okay okay
so so if you go to this this is the this
is the start URL that we started with
and we need to get the hyperlinks for
this thing right each of the restraint
so what I did is I inspected this what
what sort of item it is and then got to
know it's a h3 and the class is title
okay and then inside that you go to a
and then H ref this is the this is the
URL you need so and that's how I got h3
class title inside that a and then H ref
okay so we need to illed here so to
yield scrapey dot request that we saw
earlier then this is the absolute URL we
need okay and then what we have to do is
this is the parser which can parse this
kind of page right this is this is the
page it's a it's listed the restaurants
are listed but what we actually need is
an another parser to parse this kind of
page right so so what we need to do is
like we need to write another parser to
to scrape these kind of pages so we are
actually creating requests for this page
here here we're actually creating
requests but we have to we have to give
a different parser for it okay so how
you do that is give you a call back and
then serve dot
okay so we're going to write a new
parser here so name it as parse
restaurant okay
so clear so far so we are going to write
a new parser for to scrape a page where
you have like restaurant details ok now
we need to identify expert few important
XPath that we would need in this page
for example the name rating and then
longitude latitude that's that's we will
capture so location of the restaurant
it's rating and its name okay so here in
this image we will have the ratings if
you inspect here if you inspect here and
then this is the image and then it has
the rating value the property is rating
value and the content is 4.5 this I know
because I already like prepared for this
where you get rating so I know here so
we can we can reduce the export for this
okay weighting is equal to
image culture rating value you and then
what we need is content okay this should
give us the rating information let's see
this is just the right expert okay we
are getting that cool and then we also
need to do extract maybe first because
we will have only one in this page okay
clear
so let's eat this
okay is it clear now clear any doubts
huh yeah I this is okay I need to add
name and etcetera also so I thought of
like let's test once before we move on
okay so the judge it should give only
rating now let's see how how the
execution goes hey did you get to what
you what you wanted
you asked me to get back to school so
let's run it okay we got ratings for the
first page actually okay now what we had
to also do is get the name and name and
other latitude/longitude information
right so we have I have already
identified that those information
available in in a map here okay
okay so this this has like all the
information we need so this I have done
my homework to like understand where it
is so this is something you may have to
do for your projects you have to
identify where your interesting
information is there identify that
location and then start writing the
XPath so here I know like this map
container has all the information that
we need so you guys able to see that
really okay so it's it's a steel class
equal to map container that's where you
have the information you have data
latitude data longitude and the name
okay let's let's create expert for that
and then get the name under the details
okay
equal to response
because it do
China and then get your name dot extract
first
we also need to do the same thing for
latitude/longitude here we need to
change it to latch and LNG longitude so
let's switch test the export ones ok
good so the text path is correct and
latitude export should also be correct
okay so longitude so it's a it's a
developer tool if you go to Chrome and
then you do car commands command F
command F in Mac so there should be some
way here the command D F works but I
don't know what command in Windows
okay so and also we can add URL
okay
okay so I think you should have all the
information that we need No
hey URL rating URL this is the rating
this is the name this is the longitude
and this is the latitude okay so we got
all the information that we need but
there is a small problem here because
it's only scraping the first page rate
we need to like only first page
information is not sufficient what we
need to do is we need to add requests
for other pages as well so as you
remember this is parts is the function
that actually parts the list of
restaurants right so we need to create
requests for the next hyperlink so how
do you do that
export souls we have to find where the
next link is there in this page so if
you go here and see there is a next
button here and we need to like identify
what is the X part of that why'd you
finish back here so this is the this is
the hyperlink and if you can see here
there is a text next so it becomes easy
for us like what you do is
yeh text equal to next so they should be
is it right
that's verify yeah we got it
you need to just close this okay so this
big this is the URL hyperlink for the
next button okay we got the expert for
the next button and you need to extract
it first
okay sorry and following so far next we
need to also do the same thing for this
else so absolute URL we already know
they should only get relate you absolute
URL will do next next absolute URL okay
and now if we need to what we have to do
what we have to do now we have to end
you guys following or so it's the lunch
time guys hungry so by the way what time
you have to like break for lunch now 20
minutes okay give me 10 minutes okay
quickly finish okay yield we need to ill
derail response so sorry you reminded me
of lunch no scrappy dot request of this
next absolute URL and call back what
should I set the callback exactly
so if dot parse right okay then this
should be it
so this this will this becomes a
recursive function recursive call to
these parts
this parts function is a parser for
parsing the page that leads to the
restaurants and parse restaurant is the
parser that parses the detailed page
right yeah so I think this should be it
hopefully it works let's see
hey cool we got something let's see what
it is
okay so we got Hey
pick out only 31
okay let me just verify the cord it
should be some problem
here's G bugging
so line 15
okay so let me let me just cover the
other part I wanted to cover like how
what visualization we can do with our
with a data that is existing okay we
have some data so help something called
cartodb right so if you go and like
create an account here so you can
actually like just dump this CBS data
and do some visualizations
trying to decide
you mean to say like even even the
website changes it should work kind of
thing yeah we do how like done some
something of that sort but it's not very
very like a foolproof okay you can do
some guessing work like okay if it is if
you want to like get the name of the
person if you find an email address you
can do some intelligence stuff Slough to
check for surrounding things but but
it's very hard to like right right a
spider for changing websites you have to
have to like change small modifications
it might have like changed some XPath
it's a it's a minor fix in the spider
but it's very hard to write like
resilient spiders
okay I think it's like taking a little
more time than it usually takes so what
I'll show is like I have already like
created some other output files like
generated out of the same things I think
I can show that in the map view so this
is this is something that you will get
like end of the day like you have you
know like where is the concentration of
restaurants around this area like based
on the rating so if higher the rating
like the darker is what it is showing
because this choropleth is based on on
the rating so I have chosen the rating
here so if it is 5 and then then it
shows really darker so and then you can
add like add which columns to show when
you click on it etcetera so it will it
is showing the name and the rating of
the of the restaurant so so what
basically the point is like with with
this you can actually like know where is
the where is the high rated restaurant
concentration is and then just you you
go to that area so that the the options
and the better food you get it will be
more there's the there's a primary like
business case I wanted to show here so
so you know like here here there are
very less restaurants and also like less
less rated it if you go here there are
higher rated more restaurants and
probably you take that route so this was
this was the intention to show a
business value behind scraping okay so
here we had few more slides but I know
you're all tired and like break for
lunch
so I'll just right away go to the last
one like mandatory slates sales slide so
like what we do in scraping hub so this
is like off-the-shelf data sets we sell
directly some of the data sets and web
screen
being projects closed baser platform is
there where you can actually run your
spiders you can deploy spiders there and
and it will serve it will run on the
servers and you can you can hit like try
scraping Capcom PI data NYC to get
registered player on user platform for
free like you can run one concurrent job
one job and keep data for around seven
days you can try it out try that okay
hope you guys followed but I can share
you github code